today the city celebrated earth day  arbor day and children's day with a tree  planting and festival at gary reese  freedom park in the east valley get  outdoors nevada partnered with envy  energy staff to plant 51 trees the  festival also had music kids activities  free popsicles and food trucks what a  deal the organization says they host  volunteer events every weekend  we have lots of great corporate partners  as well as community volunteers that  want to get out on a saturday morning  give back to their community we do tree  plantings as well as litter cleanups in  addition we partner with some of the  federal agencies to get out on the  public lands and beautify those spaces  volunteers planted lace bark elm net  leaf hackberry and willow acacia which  are all desert adapted trees